I think we've got to be intellectually
more engaged with the harder questions
for me yes we all believe in tax cuts we
all believe or many of us believe in a
small state but how do we actually get
there which taxes should we be cutting
first there's an argument and I that's
what I liked about the AUM statement
yesterday was that they were reducing
business taxes bit of income taxes to
encourage the investment but there's got
to be a staged and processed look at tax
reductions but also a question that I
know you're very interested in about
what the state should provide and also
finding greater efficiencies because
it's very much the labor argument that
by spending more money somehow you get
better outcomes but we've got to be much
more rigorous about public expenditure
and that's a debate that looking back I
wish we'd had last year we'd have been I
think better to be bolder on public we'
have had a lot of flack from the left
obviously but I think we've got to be
level with people on on public
expenditure